[Music]
i have been in an expired relationship
for 30 years
how do i get rid of it
wow
yeah i wish i could ask questions back
like is this a friendship
is this a romantic
you know uh relationship is this a
business partnership like i'm gonna
assume it's a marriage okay and we'll
approach it from there and then i think
it will be applicable
to friendships as well right and so
how do you know a
friendship has expired how do you know
that a marriage has expired how do you
know that
a
co-worker relationship has expired i
think fundamentally it's all the same
yeah it's just that you're
in the marriage you're much more
entangled with someone right
you've gotten to a point where and this
actually happened in my first marriage
where we were basically roommates at
some point
i think this happens with a lot of
people
you are a roommate
and you have shared finances you're sort
of splitting the bills with each other
yeah
you're splitting some household
responsibilities and chores
but the same
passion is gone yeah every relationship
especially
intimate relationships like a marriage
or boyfriend girlfriend whatever
uh we talk about this and love people
use things every relationship has three
requires three things in order for it to
last long term
the relationship must have chemistry
that's usually what happens first
and then it must have compatibility and
it must have love
those are the three things we talk about
this is from dr christopher ryan
and
i think it's the reason that yours and
my relationship has lasted so long
there's a particular chemistry between
the two of us we can finish each other's
sentences we can
we have a dynamic or we can go back and
forth i know how generally you're going
to answer a question you're you know how
i'm going to answer once we can volley
back and forth relatively well yeah but
we can we're also comfortable sitting in
silence with each other
and so the there's a particular
chemistry between the two of us and i
think it's true with anyone else that
you work with live with are around
regularly semi regularly
there's a chemistry that's an important
component
then there's love
well to love someone is to see them for
who they are without trying to change
them this is simultaneously the easiest
and the hardest thing to do
because you don't have to do anything to
love them
love does not require doing
i can't do more love
i can simply
see you for who you are as soon as i
want to change you
that relationship has expired
or at least that portion of the
relationship has expired oh interesting
because to want to change someone is to
unlove them and so if i want you to
change i want you to do this i want you
to do this i want you to do that that
means i'm not happy with who you are and
therefore i'm not happy with the
relationship it's not wrong or bad it's
but it's not loving
and then the third thing is
compatibility and this is usually where
relationships expire
because you can have chemistry and you
can have love
but the two of you aren't compatible at
all and there are certain
non-negotiables that you can't even
negotiate on in a marriage just like if
one person wants to have kids and the
other doesn't
uh oh
that's a problem because there isn't a
well i guess we'll just have half a kid
i'll get you sort of pregnant um now
there's there are other non-negotiables
some people might want monogamy and
other people might want to be in an open
relationship
now
if you're both stuck there
then that's non-negotiable yeah right i
mean you can negotiate all you want but
like
what's going to happen is one person's
going to be deprived in the relationship
yeah and therefore you're going to drag
the other person in your direction
you're going to drag them toward
monogamy or you're going to drag the
person toward an open relationship
therefore the relationship is expired at
this point now yeah here's the beautiful
part about this
the relationship as it's currently
constituted is expired
it doesn't mean the entire relationship
is expired i like that
you know um sometimes when they make jam
there's like a layer of mold on the top
shout out to squirrel yeah
[Laughter]
and
you often scrape the mold off or if you
uh dry aged beef you've seen dry aged
beef before yeah it's just a layer of
mold on top of you have to cut the mold
off so
that is technically ex literally expired
yeah but you cut off the part that has
expired
and now you have
what you were actually looking for the
whole time
did you enjoy this video if so you can
listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists today your support keeps
our podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free